is the devil a woman there are things
male and female I find that they are I
like to think if you think about the
devil being a because the devil is that
it's a it's the temptation you know the
devil you could feel your train just my
train will be on the tracks man I'm
cruising you know doing good things for
myself waving at a neighbor having a
milk having a fresh milk you know doing
nothing bad nothing I see maybe a bowl
of caramels or Weathers originals I pass
them up I'm good I'm good baby I'm cool
I go for a run I go for a jog you know I
wave it a neighbor had a puppy
you know tickle a book take a look
tickle a dove and then suddenly my train
the tracks they roll right past that
temptation station and the Satan's
little cat house right there and my
brakes they I don't even put the brakes
on but they put themselves on my brakes
don't put them like who's running the
brakes and that's a temptation man
temptation is such a dangerous it's such
a dangerous little microwave isn't it
because it looks warm in there it looks
fun it's lit up you open that microwave
it looks lit up in there
and then you walk in there the door
closes Starsky things start cooking the
floor starts spinning around in a circle
you got all your loved ones are looking
in at the window this is just a
temptation man at a beta it'll bait you
and then it'll dam DayTripper next thing
you know you trapped into a relationship
with the devil you know that's one thing
I miss remember when every when regular
things were temptation and you mill
around long enough and then the only
person the only thing that the only you
know you've seen everything enough
you've collected enough basketball cards
and you know you've you know you've
watched enough you you know you've
you've gone to the beach enough times
and you've you know touch the the
nipples of enough ladies or kissed
enough women or or and then the only
temptations around is that it's this
it's really the Dark Arts at that point
you know the only person that's still
stirring the bowl with the wooden spoon
and you look at the hand you see that
it's got dark nail polish on it and
that's the devil man he's the only one
who's still tempting you
he's still stirring you dirty like that
so you got to find those inner
temptations you know that's what I have
to find anyway I got to find you know
you got to fight the dark arts man and
when we stay in the good space man I do
believe that good things can happen for
us you know and we get tempted man we
see that wooden spoon stirring up all
the goodies but we don't see the hand
that's turn it
the hand got dirty fingernail polish on
it and that hands got a the knuckles of
a of a leper and I don't know what a
leper is actually but I think it's but
it's just got you know that's the devil
good evening good afternoon and other
times thanks for watching that video you
just saw I mean it was okay but the next
video you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watch this one